welcome back to new rock stars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about which
villains in the mtu are perfect to fill
thanos's hole
wait what
[Music]
my name is empty and i'm here today with
the wonderfully amazing off-screen
producer brandon oh hello i'm so happy
to be back dude i love doing big
questions with you man it's great you're
so smart and you're factual and you're
with it you're with it i just got a lot
of confidence in the that i say
that's all fake it till you make it
that's how i like it that's the way i
live kids whatever you have to say in
class it doesn't matter if the answer is
wrong or right you just say it with
confidence say it with confidence that's
how politicians work
hey they're all you know in office got
him all right hit me with that big
question brandon okay okay mt here's the
deal all right i'm i'm loving the new
what if series it's been great
the second episode showed us a timeline
where thanos was dissuaded from pursuing
his infamous plan involving the infinity
stones and maybe a little genocide i
don't know it's debatable uh and he's
pursuing a life of good right okay yeah
and in this absence the collector he
gets yoked up right it gets just
uh and he takes up he takes up the role
of being like a big bad in that universe
right but if you think about it we
already have our own timeline in the mcu
where there is no thanos
where that younger thanos from 2014 he
went all the way to the future just to
get dusted what a waste buddy that's
amazing but now you know the tv smh what
was he thinking but the tva has showed
us like this made a new whole timeline
right so now there's this
2014 mcu timeline that has no thanos so
that leads us to this week's big
question who would become the new
conqueror in that 2014 timeline that's
missing thanos
that is a great question brandon well i
think it's time to invoke the mcu's 25th
amendment and look at the line of
succession for marvel's big bats and if
thanos was the president who would slide
in to replace him if he was no longer
able to perform his duties so let us go
through the list and theorize who might
be a worthy successor to the purple man
with an attitude problem and you're
going to help me out with this one
brandon because you had a long list of
uh people that want thanos job and i
know you're all sitting there screaming
at your screens yelling it's gotta be
king it's of course it's gotta be king
and he would certainly make sense as a
worthy successor to thanos but at the
same time we know that he who remains is
still controlling the timelines at this
point and he allowed thanos to hop to
the future and then get destroyed so it
was all part of his plan so i don't
think kang is too concerned with coming
in and taking over one timeline because
he's got a much bigger aspiration so i
think king would continue to wait for
his moment to begin conquering multiple
timelines and universes and wouldn't
just focus on this timeline now that
makes total sense why is ken gonna worry
about this one little timeline you know
he's got bigger fish to fry you gotta
catch them all it's like it's ash stop
that pikachu was like you know what this
is good i'm gonna focus on this one
pikachu i'm not gonna focus on the other
pokemon okay i mean one pokemon's a lot
of work i don't know why you bother
getting hundreds of them but i guess you
gotta feel like one pet is a lot of work
right right i'm not out there trying to
collect all dogs okay
mtu brought up kang but that also you
know like i think a lot of people are
thinking the celestials right they
should be the
bad in this timeline but they're a very
big picture type of force right you know
they're there at the beginning and the
end they've seen multiple universes and
like they go around spreading life uh
they're already wiping out whole planets
and civilizations whenever they feel
like it so i don't think they need to
take over for thanos like thanos is just
like a little street corner criminal to
them like they're these are the big
bosses of the universe you know they
gotta hover and get refused
they don't care about this one little
timeline so yeah forget about kang
forget about the celestials yeah i think
those two we can just easily get those
two out of the way but now that we do
got those two out of the way let's look
at the line of succession after them
because right at the top of the list i
think you have to put everyone's
favorite god of mischief mr loki himself
as sylvie suspected at the end of the
series finale where she was like you
just want this for yourself don't you he
was like no totally i don't i love you i
love myself
loki has got to be the first up in the
line of succession to replace thanos
because he is burdened with glorious
purpose after all and he is well aware
of the infinity stones and thanos's
quest for them and the power vacuum left
behind but thanos exited 2014 with most
of his army meant that loki could slide
right in and you know continue his quest
if he really wanted to because if you
remember in avengers 1 he was very much
working with thanos and when he failed
he sort of like it was like hey all
right so i'm just going to sneak away
from pandos and like because i messed up
so now that if thanos is gone you can
just be like oh i can just fill in this
vacuum because i already know all these
plans because we used to work together
yeah he's seen the blueprints he knows
what to do um so this is still a loki
that is learning evil like he hasn't had
experience the events of thor ragnarok
that would make him more of like a nice
person and he got beat in the battle of
new york and is presumed to be dead
following the events of thor the dark
world and he's hiding out on asgard
pretending to be odin so once he finds
out that thanos the black order and most
of his army is gone loki could literally
slip right in and take control of
whatever forces thanos left behind
because he wouldn't be in the position
to do so with odin's army yeah and he's
got that silver tongue like he could
convince any leftover thanos
uh loyalist to like work for him you
know because right he's like hey we got
benefits we got yeah so you want to come
like you can come hang out on asgard you
can like use the hot tubs it'll be
totally cool just help me out it's
totally we got gold toilets and
everything and plus again since he's
pretending to be odin at the moment he
could have access to any weapons or
powerful magic items hidden within
odin's vaults and he probably wouldn't
even make another attempt on conquering
earth until he grabbed a couple of
infinity stones first but i could
definitely see loki taking over the
thanos-less timeline at the end of the
day because it's just what he wanted to
do his whole aspiration was to rule i
don't think he would he would have
stopped with earth anyway if he did win
avengers no thanos is gone he's like i'm
gonna get some infinity stones go back
to earth make them look like chumps and
get what's mine yeah he's not nice level
man he's still he's stolen
he hasn't met bobius he's a husband yet
it's true well we talked about loki but
i think the next to the line of
succession after loki would definitely
be
ronan the accuser okay
uh we already saw in the first guardians
of the galaxy movie that he was tired of
being like thanos's errand boy you know
when he got his hands on that power
stone he was like screw you mad titan i
don't need you i'm gonna do this myself
let's go let's go so at this point he's
starting to look for the stuff he knows
where the power stone is
he sent his guy to go get it and all of
a sudden like thanos disappears he's
probably like well i'm just gonna
continue on this job uh and take over
the universe right he's got a big old
warship already the dark aster uh he's
got those sakarin insectoid soldiers
that are who's got his own army already
very handsome soldiers yes very handsome
soldiers and plus you know he's he's
like a cree warrior so he's a tough guy
he can get his hands dirty like loki's
not gonna do a hand-to-hand fight with
anybody if he can avoid it
ronit will get his he'll crush a few
heads with his hammer uh if he needs to
again he was at all the meetings with
loki he saw the blueprints he knows the
plan so he's like well i'll just
continue doing this and like while in
2014 you know he's on the outs with the
kree empire like they're kind of like
he's a weird fanatical we got these
peace treaties don't worry about him uh
but i think if the cree saw
if ronan was able to get his hands like
one or two affinity stones and showed
back up uh at the cree home base they'd
be like okay well we'll follow you now
you're doing a great job let's get back
to comments let's do our thing i can see
that i will have to teach you how to be
villains
and plus ronan knows about captain
marvel because he dealt with her in 1995
so he would be like look guys we're
taking over for thanos but we have to
look out for this chick i'm not being
derogative to women that's ronin calling
her a check uh
we have to look out for this
this woman uh who's very powerful uh
and so he'd be ready for us so i think
you know because i think thanos was kind
of taking surprise by captain marvel
where she showed up in 2023 so like he
would be ready for so he i think he
could
he could have a good plan to get rid of
her he knows about the stones he's got
the big ship he's got the armory i think
he very quickly becomes like the next oh
yeah oh yeah like like you mentioned
like this dude is like this huge like
religious zealot and he has a bone to
pick with anybody who's messed with
decree throughout history zandar the
scrolls like is he would literally go
like you said go to the cree take that
over have the entire kree empire
he's gonna be like we're gonna go to war
with everybody or everybody yeah and
that's how he does it i mean i can see
it like the dark aster lands the craze
like what is what is this guy doing back
here you know the supreme intelligence
is like get this out of
here i mean you're like look at these
boom got two infinity stones they'd be
like
i'm like boom you looking for this boo
yeah boo yeah ronin
very great contender but another great
contender as we see in episode two of
what if is of course the collector
tannelier tavonne he showed us in that
episode how he could become the biggest
bad in the universe because you know he
just got the juice he's got the whole
tavonne corporation he's ready to roll
and he's got at least one infinity stone
in his collection in 2014 and is well
aware of its importance and power as
he's like super old he's one of the
elders of the universe and it wouldn't
take much for the collector to move on
from collecting singular items to
collecting entire planets and
civilizations because this is something
that he does in the comics as well and
if anything the fact that he's one of
these long-living elder beings might
keep him from doing the hard work of
conquering everything right now so maybe
in one timeline he becomes the big bad
crime lord that we saw in what if and
that's probably just a rare occurrence
but if we're going to consider the
collector we should probably also
consider his brother
the grand master baby
you know you know how brothers are if if
one sees the other doing something they
want to do it too you know you'd be like
wow i'll take over the galaxy
yeah but the grand master just like the
collector is another one of these elder
beings who've been there since the
beginning of the universe uh he loves
being in charge as we saw he wants to
party all the time he loves having like
subjects that adore him uh and he loves
forcing people to battle to their death
for his amusement and the amusement of
his citizens very roman in his style you
know that's how the romans did it right
before rome fell apart uh entertainment
for the masses circus and the people
it's a fun time it's a fun time until it
ends
[Music]
it was through this process of battle
elimination that he came to like have
and possess his grandest champion the
hulk uh and with the hulk alone the
great master could start taking over the
universe the problem is you just have to
like convince the hulk to go destroy a
planet for you because like the hulk
loves
being the the grand champion for the
grand master but i think he likes the
attention he's getting he likes being
loved because on earth he's like seen as
a monster so he's happy to like kill a
few you know random gladiators if it
makes all the people love him and he
gets you know this the penthouse suite
and he gets all the hot tubs he can
he can afford uh
so 100 like
i feel like hulk like not bruce banner
but hulk in particular is very
manipulative oh yeah if you just were
like hey wait everyone would love you if
you just took over the planet you know
uh you know zandar you'd be like okay
yeah i'll do it i'll smash women and
children
got that big green ego baby he loves a
little attention but yeah if you if the
grand master tried to be like okay i
like the fighting now go destroy planet
he might not like be so obedient about
that so while the grandmaster he wields
a lot of power on sakar
but i don't know if he would
want to fill in for thanos because it
seems like a lot of work you know he's
pretty like set especially in like 2014
he's pretty set on sakara i don't think
he would like necessarily want to like
try and push his influence out into the
taking over the whole universe right but
i mean we saw that you know that could
be abandoned really easy through
evolution and you kind of like start all
over again so
if if in that timeline without thanos
the revolution still somehow happens on
sakhar he might be like well i guess i
gotta start all over i might as well
take over the whole universe if i'm
gonna do it you know what would be crazy
well first of all sorry my brain is i'm
doing a weird crazy thing give me the
crazy
you know what would be crazy with the
grandmaster like what if he did have
this aspiration to take over the
universe and he did but he forced every
planet to fight amongst each other this
is like so he takes one like the the
last person left on each planet for one
big
like grand master tournament and so like
the last person in the universe would be
like the winner of the tournament and so
like he just wanted to find like an
equal he's like i want to find the
greatest champion of them of all time
and so that'd be a great interesting way
for like a what-if episode for the grand
master if you didn't want it but he
don't want to have people around so
maybe not like everyone on the plane has
to fight but like every planet has to
send their best champion right if your
champion loses i wipe out your planet
that's how it works
yeah it's very rick and morty like show
me what you got
[Music]
show me what you've got he wants to see
like who's your best fighter that would
be so much fun right and then whatever
planet is left he just like calls that
home and they all hang out on one planet
and party all the time that's it and
have us that's the goal
marvel should legit just hire us to make
a whole grand master episode because
that's literally it right there i don't
know why they haven't hired us i don't
know why seriously our emails are on
display
don't display our emails
alright so another great contender to
fill in for thanos would be of course
ego the living planet
volume 2. he was already well on his way
to totally reshaping the universe in the
way that he saw fit he just needed that
spark from one of his offspring uh but
with thanos disappearing in 2014 so does
the original catalyst for the creation
of the guardians of the galaxy so peter
has no power stone to take to the
antiques dealer on xandar and thus never
gets in a scuffle with rocket groot and
gamora then there is a good chance that
the guardians of the galaxy as we know
them never come together if you know how
i feel why would you say that but this
also means that peter never has a
dance-off with ronan dance-off bro
me and you leading to the moment when he
holds the power stone and it was that
moment that tipped ego off to the
whereabouts of his long-lost peter quail
and assuming ego does eventually track
down his son he might be able to
convince him to join his plan and since
this world would be a peter who doesn't
have the new family of the guardians
that he might be eager to join his pups
in a universe conquering spree and i
think ego would be a great replacement
for thanos assuming that he could find
his battery of a son and i think that
that's what this episode ends on it's
like peter doesn't have that his family
to to make him a good person and he's
probably a lot like t'challa at the
beginning of the episode where he's like
i'm living in this small town i hate
missouri
sucks like i want i want to feel special
and here comes his dad in the diner hey
kid
boy do i got a surprise for you you are
the most special boy in the universe
something special right but this ego is
gonna have a lot of work to do right
because like
peter does the peter in the what if
episode has no idea about like the
cosmos in space and uh flying around and
zandarians and all that so he's got to
like explain a lot you know he's just
some schmuck working at dairy queen the
same dairy queen where his parents you
know dropped some seed in the wood which
is pretty messed up
i wonder if he's aware of how far away
he is from his conception point i don't
know you had to make it weird uh
pretty disturbing um but yeah so if we
think about like this 2014 timeline like
you said you gotta you got a peter quill
who's
maybe assumingly maybe still with the
ravagers at that point because like he
if he doesn't go on his little guardians
adventure
he sticks with them
uh if ego does eventually track him down
there i'm sure he kills yondu right away
because he pissed at him uh and then
yeah maybe this peter isn't so
you know keen on yeah without any like
family to tying him down he'd when the
ego kind of presents this plan to him
he'd probably be like hell yeah uh let's
do it and then he still gets used as a
battery but he may be a battery but he's
our battery maybe ego would give him
some agency let him be like uh his
lieutenant or something like that but i
could i could definitely see ego if that
plan went if that plan worked because we
saw just a little bit of juice and
planets were getting like taken over by
the the ooze uh so
if if we can find the secret of the ooze
the secret ingredient is crime
right that'd be crazy i mean it's just
like boom just like that he could have
the whole universe peter finding his
family was a major necklace event yeah
from keeping that from happening you
said it yourself
we're the guardians of the galaxy right
thank god thank you thank god for
raccoons that's what i'm saying all
right i got another candidate for you mt
and this one hit me is a god okay
uh let's talk about hell okay i love
that dog right i love that guy oh my god
i sir
all right so let's assume that in this
2014 timeline like odin's still pretty
close to fading away forever thus
releasing hella you know
again odin like give your kids a heads
up like maybe five minutes before she
shows up maybe this is something you
kept them for like years in advance i
mean what the
you're really like oh yeah i totally
forgot i grounded your older sister
i mean they've been alive for
tens of thousands of years and in like
the last blip of their life he's like oh
yeah by the way you're adopted and uh
your sister uh she's more powerful than
you and she's coming right
now
right terrible
okay so let's assume like hella so hell
is you know she first thing she's gonna
do right is conquer the nine realms okay
because this is a this is a timeline
where ragnarok's not gonna happen like
it happened in the main mcu timeline
because so many things have shifted at
this point so how as she gets into
asgard she eats out thor and loki
because she's more powerful than them
however she does it and so now she's got
she's gonna take over the nine realms
first uh and raise her army of the dead
and all that
the rest of the universe i don't know uh
you know she did tell she did say that
she was kind of mad at odin for stopping
at nine realms like let's go get some
more that's true uh because as you said
mt like realms are just like places in
the universe right so she might want to
conquer more of the universe uh but i
think the biggest
problem for her is like
asgard is her weak spot right that's
where she gets all her powers from so
yeah she could start taking over she
could be a really big bad force but if
anyone figures out like oh all we got to
do is like blow up asgard that's gonna
be a pr that's gonna be a constant
problem for her that's her like achilles
heel but i don't i don't know if she'd
wanna like take over the whole
universe
maybe it just seems like so much work
ain't nobody got time for that but she
does love having she is the goddess of
death so
yeah she wants more dead people right
exactly like i think that thanos mission
would be something that she would really
want because it would increase her her
maybe her authority because she is the
god of the dead yeah the more people the
bigger her army gets right i feel like
she probably wouldn't want to stop at
half
she would probably want to go
at least 95 maybe just like to have a
good
chunk of dead people to make sure that
she never loses her power but you know
that i never really considered that what
if um
hella is responsible for the zombie
episode of what if oh that would be
really we're gonna find out because she
is the goddess of death yeah so
how would she factor into a marvel
zombie scenario we'll find out soon oh
man i loved him in the what if episode
that we're talking about when the
collector put on her her hat oh that was
that was badass dude it was ass i mean
it started like it works for him
that was cool i didn't realize the
swords came from the hat but it makes a
lot of sense so of course we just did
hell up we got to talk about odin
because he's the big dog he's the big
dog of asgard and he's like the all
father of pretty much all the universe
essentially and he's a god that's done a
fair amount of conquering in his past
and though his current old man owed
himself in 2014 seems pretty content
with just living out his days in peace
hiding out in a retirement home on earth
and he's probably also well aware that
his end is near so unless he wanted to
gather the stones to prolong his life i
doubt he would be too keen on taking
thanos's place
i'm too old for this
because he's a nice dude yeah he's
chilled out yeah i mean he conquered the
nine realms the the hard way and then he
felt bad about it as he got older and
he's like i'm sorry put hello away in
the cave or wherever he hides her
uh so yeah i don't know if he would like
suddenly in like his his retirement
years be like well real quick i want to
take over for for thanos but yeah i mean
you're right though if he was like oh if
i need to get the stones i can prolong
my life and increase my
you know my odin force uh maybe he might
be into it
is getting kind of weak in my old age i
need to listen fellas we're all trying
to increase our open force out there
this next one empty i gotta i got a a
good one for you okay this is gonna bend
your mind a little bit this is a double
okay a double deck or two this is kind
of two people i'm
putting together as a successor for
thanos uh it's gonna blow your mind a
little bit okay chip and dale chip is
gay the rescue rangers
they're not here to rescue anymore
they're here to do
some death
let's discuss the possibility of the
ancient one taking over
uh for thanos and not just the ancient
one but the ancient one and dormammu
okay hear me out hear me out okay okay
okay we already know that like the
ancient one is aware of the infinity
stones how they work and all that uh and
she can see through time uh up to the
point that she dies right so she knows
that she's gonna die at some point in
the near future if this is 2014 she's
got four years
it's coming she's aware of the infinity
stones she can kind of sense magical
shifts in the universe i think she would
notice if thanos suddenly went missing
like in a if he if he goes through his
like quantum time tunnel she's gonna be
like well that was weird something weird
just happened out there she'd do her
little magic
and she'd figure it out right
so i think there's two possibilities
here of ancient one slash dormammu
taking over thanos one is like the
ancient one's like okay maybe if i can
get some more stones because they got
one they have the time stone she's like
maybe if i get some more stones i can
get rid of dormammu because i'm using
dormammo to stay alive i'm the only one
who can i have to do this i mean she
makes some excuses for using
dark magic she's like listen i'm the
only one who can do this job i'm the key
i'm the only one to get the job done
yeah you gotta wait till steven strange
comes around then i will die okay just
give me some time and if i told you
everything else that you don't already
know you'd run from here in terror so
okay so maybe she's like all right
thanos is gone i'm gonna go i'm gonna
take up his mission i'm gonna get the
rest of these infinity stones and then i
can get rid of dormammu it probably
won't work out for her but you know that
could be one way uh the other way it
could be like dormammu is aware that
thanos is gone
and somehow
gets into like the ancient one's mind i
don't know because they have some sort
of connection she's drawing that power
and maybe he convinces her like hey
listen we got to go out there and we got
to do this you could extend your life
you could live for longer
you know you could be powerful you could
be you're already the source's sorcerer
supreme but you could be even more
incredibly powerful right uh so i and
like dormammu kind of talks her into
like doing this and like maybe she she
leans to the dark side a little she's
like you know what you're right girth
i'm tired of this let's go let's get out
there let's do some damage uh so that's
that's that would be like my craziest
succession is
uh the ancient one and dormammu seeing
thanos gone and being like let's do this
let's take over she gives dormammu a
couple planets to eat uh and then like
she she runs the she runs the universe
bro i think the first of all that is
crazy and i love that but with
dormammu he's just one entity in a vast
multiverse so what if dormamma was like
yo ancient one what if we just go on an
alliance you know you you've been using
my stuff but like what if both of our
universes were to work together to stop
the threat coming to us because we know
that you know we got kings on the way we
got like other threats like schumacher
like there was probably some type of
multiversal war if it's not the
obviously not the way that um kang told
us but the lies of the tva but like
there has to be some type of multiversal
struggle if dormammu already has a bunch
of dimensions within his domain like you
have to fight for those probably and we
can squash the other dimensions and run
this neighborhood so we got dormammu but
here's another wild one for you what
about we gotta consider the red skull
why because he was up there on vermeer
just chilling and uh he's got he's got
some knowledge of the stones um so if
there was a way for red skull to escape
his servitude on vormir perhaps even
with the soul stone he would definitely
want to get back to his conquering ways
because that's just what he does he's
this is what he knows the best and earth
would seem like such a small price for
him at that point because he's he's been
in the universe like he's seen the
universe from the cosmic perspective so
like
he has a greater understanding of the
cosmos so it's he wouldn't stop at earth
he's going to go big he's going to go
big or go home or go back to vermeer
yeah i don't think yeah because you know
growing up as a young nazi uh he you
know his his dreams were just like let's
take over the world right but now that
he's been in space for a while he's been
hanging out on vormir maybe the whole
time we don't really know but like he's
got a whole new perspective now so he's
not going to be like i want to go back
to earth and take it over no he doesn't
care about her
he wants to take over the whole the
whole universe so yeah if he somehow
could get off of warmer i don't know how
probably just an uber probably he calls
him he's like
i think of this before
another person to consider
another kind of big bad uh certain you
know i know i know what you think mr
krabs yeah mr krabs mr fiery crabs uh
he's got his crown wiping out asgard i
mean all he really wants to do is wipe
out asgard and he seems like before he
gets a dude he seems so bored and just
tired and like tired of this uh
but like let's say he's able to finally
destroy asgard to bring the ragnarok uh
do you think like after that he might be
like whoa let's go
blow up some other planets i don't know
and if there's no because hella couldn't
stop him uh she was unable to stop him
uh so now you have this like timeline
with no thanos you know if ragnarok
comes to pass there's no thanos there no
one's got control of the infinity stones
could certainly just start reaping
across the galaxy destroying planets all
over the place he probably has beef with
like the other
you know realms that sided with the
asgardians probably against you know
certain in hell and all that stuff he's
probably going after other people like
the vanaheim and in all them yeah he's
got a list he's got a list i could
definitely see certain just going for it
and everyone just it's erupting into
this huge um universal war but yeah
those are all very worthy candidates to
replace thanos that we've seen so far in
the mcu but what about a couple of other
candidates from the marvel comics
candidates like galactus like galactus
has got to be your number one
replacement from the comics because in a
timeline without thanos galactus would
come right in and eat everything up for
sure he is there so that you know life
doesn't get out of control i feel like
because thanos is gone
galactus the universe and or eternity or
whatever um is in charge the cosmos are
going to be like we gotta there has to
be order because thanos is not wrong on
them on on the cosmic scale yeah thanos
is not wrong there has to be balance or
else things are going to
um just overpopulate there's going to be
so much life so that is what galactus
function is in the comics to eat planets
to make sure that everything's are in
check so yeah we'll probably definitely
see galactus at some point in the mcu
but this 2014 timeline with no thanos
i'm sure he'd probably show up sooner
there another another one to think about
is like annihilus
uh he comes from the negative zone i
mean he has the is it the control rod
that he uses which is kind of like an
infinity gauntlet in some ways so
you know maybe he doesn't need to worry
about the stones but without thanos i
mean he could swoop in real fast and be
like oh by the way i need to kill this
timeline uh because i got to kill all
timelines because i'm trying to live
forever yo like you know we have the
annihilation wave that's a huge story in
the comics and i really want to see that
and i feel like that's definitely coming
i think in a few years when when mcu is
like when marvel was like we need to
clear house we got too many characters
that's when they matter
comes buddy that's when it comes so we
got too many cosmic heroes we gotta get
rid of the whole shia
but also we gotta talk about doctor doom
because dr doom would be quick to
conquer the universe if given the chance
because he's all about authority or he
wants everyone to respect his authority
you will respect my authority so when he
does eventually show up in the mcu he's
going to be pissed when he realizes that
those infinity stones are already gone i
mean jesus christ thanos why would you
do that there are perfectly good
infinity stones i don't know i i don't
know if they're going to say like dr
doom was around the whole time or how
they're going to introduce him but
if they just introduce him
and he's like wait there were infinity
stones and they're gone now oh
come on
this is a bummer
that's a bummer but yes this is a pretty
solid list of worthy contenders for
succession but who would be your top
pick for succession brandon uh
you know i'm gonna have to go with my
my emo boy with the black eyes
wrote in the accuser i think okay i
think he would slip in there first in
this 2014 timeline he's gonna be the
first one to be like all right i'm doing
this then he's gonna roll up with his
dark aster blasting my chemical romance
yeah he's gonna be like don't break my
heart again i don't know i just made up
that song but uh you know he'll be
blasting some emo music and he'll be
like that's it i'm doing this i'm tired
of being pushed around it's gonna be my
timer they're gonna respect me on crete
it'll be nice to me
uh so yeah that's my top pick what about
you emt i'm gonna say ego because ego
you know he's he was already on his way
to like you know just killing everybody
anyway so like
it's just it would just be really easy
for him if he could just find another
person out there that carries a
celestial g so we don't know if peter is
the only one we don't know we don't know
what made peter special and what made
his genes um compatible with ego so
there could just easily be another a
candidate out there um it's just like a
game of like chance really but that is
it for that first question a big
question but before we continue you
should check out our most recent
addition to our latest obsession line of
shirts inspired by marvel's what if it's
a very cool design with huatu and a
really stylized look it's a limited
edition shirt so you gotta grab one
really quick and we've also got a full
line of suicide squad merch as well
including a great king shark jaws
inspired shirt super dope so
grabbing something from new
rockstarsmerch.com is an awesome way to
support the channel and to get some nods
of approval from cool strangers because
that's what we do the other day someone
tweeted at me that someone was wearing a
new rockstar shirt and they were like
like there was like a secret like
hanging between two two strangers and i
was so happy i was so happy because it
warms my heart it just it's a great way
to like you know spot other new rock
stars fans so like go to rockstars.com
so we can find out who's amongst the
family who's amongst the nerd baby
family you know what i'm saying but yes
before we dive into our bite size
questions next some words from the folks
that help bring big question to you
folks like upstart if you're carrying a
credit card balance month after month it
can feel like you're in a never-ending
cycle of debt upstart can help you make
that final payment so you can just get
ahead upstart is a fast and easy way to
pay out for debt with a personal loan
all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personally expensive
over half a million people have used
upstart to get one fixed monthly payment
upstart knows that you're more than just
your credit score and is expanding
access to affordable credit and unlike
other lenders upstart considers your
income in current employment to find you
a smarter rate for your loan so with a
five minute online rate check you can
see your rate up front for loans between
1 000 to 50 000 and you can receive
funds as fast as one business day after
accepting your loan so find out how
upstart can lower your monthly payments
today when you go to upstart.com big
question that's upstart.com bigquestion
and don't forget to use our url to let
them know that we sent you so loan
amounts will be determined based on your
credit income and certain other
information provided in your loan
application so go to upstart.com
bigquestion and uh get your debt figured
out every day delicious groceries fall
through the cracks of our food system
just because of how they look in 2019
alone 35 of the food supply went unsold
or uneaten in the u.s imperfect foods is
turning this around by sourcing quirky
but delicious foods and delivering them
to you in a way proven to reduce
emissions imperfect foods is a grocery
delivery service has created an entire
line of sustainable groceries that taste
delicious make a difference embrace
imperfection and get your groceries
delivered weekly with imperfect foods
all you have to do is sign up
personalize your weekly order and then
shop online each week and get groceries
that help you invest in a better food
system all delivered to your front door
unlike on-demand delivery companies
imperfect delivers by neighborhood a
unique model that produces 25 to 75
percent fewer emissions than individual
trips to the grocery store right now
imperfect foods is offering our
listeners 20 off your first four orders
when you go to imperfectfoods.com
and make sure to use the promo code big
question again twenty percent off your
first four orders that's up to an eighty
dollar value at imperfectfoods.com using
promo code big question try imperfect
foods now for a limited time get twenty
percent off your first four orders go to
imperfectfoods.com and use bigquestion
to sign up now it is time to enter our
bite size questions and brandon i've got
a question for you our first buy size
question is how did pre-serum steve's
pants grow with his body to still fit
his post serum self a very good question
i know i know i know what you're
thinking is this like another case of
the magical stretchy pants in the marvel
universe allah bruce banner and the hulk
okay i don't think so and just to be
sure i went back and i checked the
videotape frame by frame i checked the
tape i popped on my jbl's and i got in
close and stared at steve's body all
right so i went to the scene from the
nfl i know i never i never saw that
scene so many times i went and watched
it over and over again going through
this the scenes just before like scrawny
steve is boosted up with the serum uh it
looks like he's wearing like really
baggy pants and you know this is the
1940s and like baggy pants are like in
style it's pretty normal it's not like
those like tight pants we wear today you
know there was just like a little more
give in the pants but his pants because
everyone was listening to nwa dude right
right
but these these pants he's wearing
they're like very baggy and they're also
like super long
on his legs
uh like once steve gets the serum and is
all jacked up uh the pants are
noticeably tighter uh and they have
because now they have to fit in those
like thick thighs and those hammies you
know what i mean uh and the hem of the
pants
it's like he's wearing uh what my my
grandmother my grandma would say are
clam diggers you know capri pants
when you see like when steve's running
down the road chasing chasing that
hydrogen his his pants come to like mid
calf it's kind of ridiculous so it's
like clearly they were aware of like the
pants that they're gonna have to leave
some room in the pants first guy and
tells them like take off the hats and
the jacket and the dye but he doesn't
mention the pants so they were ahead of
they knew what was gonna happen all
right they were they were ready for this
um but i know what you guys are already
thinking
uh and you're probably writing in the
comments right now you're like what
about the belt he's wearing a belt it's
the same color as the pants it's the
army's you know uniform it's hard to see
it but he is wearing a belt you can see
the buckle pre-serum the pants do look
pretty tight around the waist like as
he's getting into the machine they're
cinched up pretty tight it's pretty
uniform but they could you know they
could have some rubber or elastic in the
waist you know because i know this is
the war effort and you're supposed to
reconserving rubber but this is part of
the war okay this was the soldier they
were making so they might have used a
little bit of rubber just in like the
pants and belt area but it's also is
when they close the chamber but there's
a moment before they get started and he
could you can't see his hands he could
go down and like loosen the belt a
little bit you know erskine could be
like steve when you get to now make uh
[Laughter]
loosen the belt because your penis is
about to get huge you're going to be
quite surprised when you look down at
your schnitzel later
i don't know i think scrawny steve was
packing he just you know i couldn't say
i will also say
i don't think steve's waist grows as
much
um because like
chris evans the actor he has a pretty
kind of
slim waist and you know uh captain
america he's he's pretty shredded he's
got big arms he's got big legs we've got
a nice tight waist i can't believe i'm
staying off got a nice tight loose
uh so i don't let's go into this brandon
what about this tight weight it's waste
i watched it so many times um yeah i
don't think that's that much um so i
don't think this is a case of magical
pants maybe a magical belt but like
everything else was kind of planned
ahead of time if you watch it he's
wearing baggier pants and then they get
tighter all right so our second bite
size question comes from i aj smith 24
from discord who asked what are blood
sports weapons made of hmm
good question iij smith so in the
original dc comics robert dubois aka
bloodsport he's like a via
a vietnam war draft dodger who's
recruited and kind of brainwashed by lex
luthor uh and he becomes like a highly
skilled assassin with a big desire to
kill superman because that's what look
lex luthor wants um he didn't really
have any superpowers to speak of but he
did have a device that allowed him to
teleport high tech weapons to his person
like whenever he needed them right uh so
this gave him an advantage in like any
combat situation and he met he had like
a plethora of tools at his disposal like
tim allen the tool man yeah he was tim
allen the tool man
so when it came to making the suicide
squad movie uh james gunn decided to
replace the teleportation device with
like the nano technology that we see
on the suit um so this means that blood
sports still had the access to the
weapons just not the teleporter which i
think kind of makes sense i think movie
audiences are more used to nano tech now
it gets used a lot uh you know iron man
obviously uses it a lot uh and so
in a lot of ways it seems less silly
than like a teleportation device even
though it's just as silly gunn told
cinema blend that he worked very closely
with the prop master and the costume
designer on this film to make sure that
all the weapons
on the suit work practically and like
actually make sense so it's not it's not
exactly like tony's nanotech iron man
suit where he can just like make any
weapon he needs and use parts of it and
you know all that kind of stuff like
bloodsport actually has to have the
pieces to put them together he can put
them together in different ways but they
actually have to be there and so they
worked really hard when they were making
the film to be like no we can't have
this there because that's where the
flamethrower is we have to pull this
from over here right and i kind of like
that part towards the end of the film
when he's kind of like searching and
he's like out of weapons he seemed to
have like a limited amount but he
doesn't you know and it gives him makes
him a little more human in that way uh
so you know he can't just like have a
grappling hook whenever he needs to he
has to be wearing like his grappling
hook sock right we don't know where he
got the nano tech from uh you know they
do say that he's shot superman which is
what happened in the comics robert
dubois shoots superman with a kryptonite
bullet and they mention amanda waller
mentions that in the film so we can
assume that maybe
a similar thing happened here where lex
luthor hooked up with him and like gave
him access to nanotechnology uh but
that's pretty much how it works nano
technology
you can tell that like james gunn is
notorious for like working very closely
with his costume designers to make sure
everything makes sense and that there's
a story behind all the pieces like i
really love that he did that because
like bloodsport really does feel like a
practical like
like character because like it's like
assembling the gun like that's the one
scene in the suicide squad that i keep
replaying in my head because it's so
badass and like they never have to
explain it it just makes sense and the
audience picks it up and it works i
really liked it but yeah thanks brandon
but now it is time for my favorite part
of the show where all the parts are my
favorite part but i do love me some
boxer scraps lots of scraps boxes grass
i love the goofy
box of scraps every time we play we say
boxes craft you have to play the goofy
version editors no
no i don't think i will so today's box
of scraps question is what if you could
replace a character in the mcu who would
you be and how would you do a better job
than the original person that's a great
question mt uh i'm not gonna replace
anyone that has to do a lot of pull-ups
i'll tell you that right now it's not
gonna be my job no no
no upper arm strength uh so i'm not
gonna replace any of those characters
all right this uh here's who i'm gonna
replace and this is gonna be
controversial because i'm gonna go with
a villain okay i would replace a villain
okay
i would replace darren cross
uh because i think he was like oh almost
there
you know he had a really good plan
uh he was just he just got a little too
crazy and i know that's his thing i know
it's his character he gets great
i think if he just captures that actor
did a really great job and did a great
great job of representing the crazy um
but i think if he just focused a little
more on his task really honed in on the
science got the science there before
trying to sell it also don't sell your
stuff to terrorists okay just don't do
it there's gonna be a buyer generally
just a bad idea you're gonna make enough
money selling your technology the clean
way okay you don't have to go to the ten
rings right off the bat all right that's
that's your first mistake you can't get
in bed with these criminal organizations
okay so i would replace
i would replace darren i would become
the yellow jacket and i would rule the
world oh that's how i would do it i feel
like you would be a boss ass yellow
jacket man i'd be a boss yelling jacket
dude
scott lang would not survive yeah oh he
would be dead dead in a second
you just like hit him with like one of
those mosquito like thomas rackets like
the fly ones
i wouldn't catch him in the little tube
i just kill him done
i think i would choose i would choose
killmonger i think oh because killmonger
was not technically wrong because
wakanda was very messed up i agree with
a lot of not help any his theories of
the nations not his practices around
them
yeah like so i i wouldn't want to like
do what killmonger did like i would not
want to like kill people to get this
done but like you know there is he does
have some sort of pull being a child of
wakanda and like you know having some
type of claim to the throne so i just
would have been like hey i'm gonna find
wakanda and then i'm going to
really just try to reform wakanda
because there are so many african
nations around them that could benefit
from the technology wakandan held so
like it was really messed up for to
chaka to to like isolate wakanda for
even though he did have a good reason to
right right you know but then mike was
trying to take advantage of them but
yeah things change situations change
okay and then you know i think you're
right like t'challa he kills his brother
or his cousin his cousin t'jala he kills
his cousin and just steals his idea and
it's like hello you win i have this
great idea
i mean that was killbonger's idea dude
that's that's that's rough i think it's
telling empty both you and i chose
villains to replace in the atmosphere we
don't want to be iron man we want to be
the bad guys i mean like the heroes got
it all together because the heroes
always win the great help yeah yeah
that's right we're trying to help the
people who need the help and it's the
villains exactly
well that is it for this episode of big
question i want to thank brandon for
joining us this episode please follow
him at grindenberric on twitter he is an
amazing man thank you for joining us
brandon thank you for having me empty
this was great this is so good and you
can of course follow me at
mastertainment on twitter if you want to
see me tweet some really weird but
most importantly subscribe to new
rockstars wherever we are especially on
youtube so you can hit that notification
bell so you can you know get
notifications whenever we upload a new
video because we'd be uploading every
day and you don't want to miss it and
make sure to go to new
rockstarsmerch.com to get some cool
shirts that all your friends will be
jealous of but yes thank you guys all
for watching and we'll see you later
goodbye
[Music]
you